reuben ramirez ricky what were the best
advantages of growing up in the streets
and what would you say to someone who's
looking to become a legitimate
businessman entrepreneur what were the
toughest obstacles maybe you want to
answer that right oh
what was the dream growing up in the
streets uh i grew up some of you guys
don't know
um i grew up in east baker school which
is the second biggest barrio in
in in california outside of east l.a um
actually the founder
of the california's mexican mafia from
baker so he grew up
six blocks from where i was grew up in
beale street um
and so there's a lot of heavy influence
there uh i think number one thing would
be to get away from those people
right which is associations get away
from people that have that mentality
uh and by the way let me make one thing
because a lot of my friends are watching
a lot of my friends i grew up in the
hood that i love very much
and there's and there and some of them
are still there some of them are out
um but it's it's limiting my association
with
the the people that had the mentality
that i used to have right
and then uh limiting my visits to the
neighborhood i'll go now to go cut my
hair to go buy
things but i don't go to visit anybody
there anymore um
uh but that's that's number one number
two is
uh one you know you and i'm just gonna
give them a shout out because you've
interviewed
me you're friends with them is uh i read
the book by robert kiyosaki rich dad
poor dad
to help me change my mentality to
understand what it is to be a business
owner and then
find a proven mentor you know in this
case i was able to first of all my my
brother got into business
uh then uh alejandro my brother shout
into this business because i come from a
family of entrepreneurs uh
that were in financial services so uh
then you know from there i was coached
by
hector and eric shout out to them and
then jose mourinho
which is the older brother older brother
sister to uh hector america and then pat
so
uh it's finding proven mentors and then
staying within that association i think
to me
my number one thing is association uh
you're gonna be a direct reflection the
five people that you're on the most that
your income is gonna be a reflection of
five people that you're around the most
and a lot of the reasons that i'm
passionate about the things that i'm
passionate about now is because pat kind
of brought light to it
so what ends up happening is that you're
kind of in the dark in a lot of things a
lot of subjects that
you're in the dark and so somebody says
hey have you looked at this all they got
to do is point a finger for you to look
at
and then you're like wow i did not know
that right so that's kind of
that's kind of the the the road that i
would say to take is
again to break it down number one get
away from associations to have the same
lifestyle
number two start reading self-developing
number three find a proven mentor you
know anybody's willing to mentor that
you admire that you know when they could
be a priest it could be a pastor you
know for us it's deadly
and on a spiritual side find it find a
way out and just stick with that
community that would be
by the way to tell you how much ricky
has influenced the latino community in
his surrounding area this is just the
beginning of what he's going to be doing
with this impact because
this messaging coming from from somebody
like this who grew up there
the level of credibility he has to say
here's where i was
here's who i was here's what i did
here's the proof
this is what i believe today we ought to
change or else uh
well i've told ricky this a million
times this is a lot of what the
republican party needs especially
no question about it like if you see a
guy like this yeah rather than the male
pale and stale crowd that you see when
they're lining up on
the trumpet pictures this is someone
that i think people can get behind
this is someone that even a democrat can
say you know what this
but you know what i think i think
there's a certain extent of the the suit
the suit let me let me let me uh
i'm gonna send something to cairo real
quick pat if you don't mind go forward i
think that uh
sometimes a lot of times uh uh what is
it called the the suit
uh may uh uh just pull that for them so
i'm gonna send a
i'm gonna send something i want you to
just take your clothes no no i'm not
gonna do that right now because
i'm actually going to send this uh i'm
going to send this like maybe while
you're doing that let me ask you a
follow-up yes sure why you're doing that
so
maybe i could pull this up real quick so
people know what i look like without a
shirt not completely just you know
so i'm going to the male model picture
no no no no no no
so um respect to you thank you for
watching what you're doing bro real talk
um you talked about limiting your trips
to the body or literally your trips to
the hood
obviously you're associating yourself
with pbd and the del toros
and the guy tons respect to them if
they're listening sapala everyone oh a
hundred percent yes
i love those guys yeah um you're talking
about eliminating how what kind of
backlash are you getting from your
people saying bro you sold out
no you're not with us you know you
talked about it i suspect
you're seeing stuff like that yeah you
know what if you know what the crazy
part is i
i don't because i'm not around them i
don't hear it
so when you go around there oh you think
you're better than me now no no actually
oh you think you're there no actually
you know surprisingly enough bro
surprisingly enough
when i like i go get my my company owns
a barber shop so i go cut my hair in the
in my neighborhood two three times a
week and when i'm getting haircuts
put it back up yeah so yeah so yeah of
course so that's that's what i look like
without a shirt so i'm completely and
that's the way my damn near
uh you know 75 percent of my body looks
i'm i'm completely tattooed
and i have my murals you know i have my
my hat the roosters where i'm from it's
big on the rooster in the rooster world
so
my family were raised yeah so so i this
is this is how i look
without my shirt i want to take my shirt
and my back i have my my back completely
tattooed as well
i grew up in the neighborhood so anyway
point is that uh uh
to answer your question though no i
don't get it i don't get a lot of it i'm
going to
i i i can see that yeah but here's why
though because
his arguments make sense there is
credence behind it
when there's credibility and weight
behind your word people have to listen
okay you have no matter how much a
person doesn't like a
doctor if a doctor's got the credibility
to say for the last you know like ron
paul would
get up and say i've done four thousand
uh uh i've delivered four thousand
babies right
if he tells you about delivering babies
guess what you have to say okay
i never delivered a baby you know four
thousand and you got credibility yeah so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]